I think it is very important I think
there is a danger that the monetary
union might break up and the view that
upon which it was set up he was added
this would be an irrevocable monetary
union so once a member leaves then the
questions might arise as to who is next
because clearly is no longer an interval
irrevocable monetary union and that was
done for a good reason currency unions
that were not irrevocable always broke
down this is what history teaches us but
the problem is that if different parts
of the currency union their economies
are performing in very different ways
it's difficult to see how you can
actually speak of a union indeed and
that's been the problem partly because
the currency union was set up as a
political project a project for peace in
Europe rather than necessarily an
economic and monetary union economics
followed and there has been a lot of
economic integration in the last few
years but unfortunately some of the
architecture is still is still imperfect
and part of the Greek problem relay
relates to art Greece has been able to
borrow excessive amounts of money in the
past and now we have an unsustainable
debt problem that needs to be somehow
addressed and it's a very very difficult
issue I understand that but as an
economist do you think it can ever be
made to work given the disparities
between the different members if you
don't accept the idea of one country
member giving effectively quite a lot of
money to another country I think it can
work and even at this late hour there
can't be an agreement that keeps Greece
within the monetary union and that would
protect the integrity of the rest of the
monetary union and what did what it
takes really it's just a lot of
imagination and a lot of willingness
when there is a will there's a way I
believed I mean Cyprus of course had its
own crisis and how is it recovered since
then actually Cyprus recovered
remarkably well from 2013 and if you
remember in 2030
teen who are facing exit of Cyprus from
the euro area but an agreement was
reached relatively quickly with the new
government which was quite painful for a
lot of people who lost money in the
banks although it's more percentage of
depositors most money nevertheless those
who lost money lost quite a bit of money
so they contributed to the bailout of
Cyprus in some sense there was massive
restructuring of the banking system
there was austerity although less less
severe compared to Greece and the
economy is doing relatively well in fact
it had the highest growth rate in the
first quarter of this year and who is
set to lose this time if there is a
restructure the restructuring of debt I
think clearly would involve some losses
for a lot others not necessarily they
did it could be basically they all the
rest of the euro area if there is some
amount of debt relief but if there is a
default the amounts that this country's
would lose would be even more for
example German it stands to lose 87 and
a half billion from a Greek default I
don't think it would lose that much from
a dead relief it would lose a lot less
and plus there would be a lot less
uncertainty as to the future of the
monetary union so they have to find some
way in which to make the greek debt
sustainable so so that we can get out of
this current crisis and you see anywhere
that Greece can recover so long as its
subject to the conditions which
according to the syriza government are
slowing it down well indeed off stereo d
has had the greater impact on was
initially anticipated and that's partly
the IMF's kind of mistake in the sense
that the way they designed the first
program wasn't quite correct in the
sense of the technical the multipliers I
had put in the fiscal multipliers so
it's not all Greece's fault in some
sense that that went wrong but that
meant that the credibility
of the program the initial program
wasn't there so that people who were
asked again and again to contribute in
terms of more and more austerity never
ending which was pretty bad and that's
why we are why we are where we are now
finding your best guess as to what you
think is going to happen well I really
hope that there will be an agreement the
last-minute agreement that would protect
Greece and we protect the rest of the
euro area I think that's very important
leaders are now writing history they can
write bad history or they can write good
history I hope they do the latter